if you haven't taken asset it's a great
drug you got to take it but you only get
six times you'll get six times your
seventh time it's just like images of
people dying your parents getting shot
in the face and then you quit doing
drugs you depress for seven years and
start stand-up comedy hi I'm Dave Ross
mr. Misha
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen from the sketch
show women please give it up I grew up
like a reserved kid
I was yeah I didn't like doing drugs or
drink through high school I didn't smoke
cigarettes cigarettes were bad you know
and so I went to college and I was like
I'm gonna keep doing that and then I met
this girl and she smoked cigarettes and
I was like I love cigarettes they're so
great I love everything about him yeah
and so I okay I went to school in LA and
I lived in a dorm on the corner of
exposition in Figueroa and oh you know
that neighborhood but and we were
watching a local news program in my dorm
room one night called the Action News
love that name action in your news yeah
election coverage with tips so we're
watching it there's a top 10 every night
on the Action News and this top 10 was
the top 10 places in Los Angeles with
the most beatings did you use any other
language besides that beatings ah it was
like we couldn't believe it we watched
the whole thing
you got to number one number one place
in LA with the most beatings is the
corner of exposition and figure on and
they showed a picture of the Chevron we
went to every day to buy cigarettes and
I was like all right well we're quitting
cigarettes for sure no more smoking
really do not need that in our lives
cool
this one anyway like six months later I
took a bunch of acid and went to the
beating Chevron to buy cigarettes and I
should say this is my first time ever
taking acid so acid hadn't made me sad
yet I don't know if you haven't taken
acid it's a great drug you got to take
it but you only get six times you'll get
six times and your seventh time it's
just like images of people dying your
parents getting shot in the face
and then you quit doing drugs you're
depressed for seven years and start
stand-up comedy hi I'm Dave Ross nice to
meet you
thank you thank you very much
I uh yeah so we're happy you know first
time bro we've been dating for six
months we're in love let's just dance
around and look at all the lights and
colors this is gonna be wonderful
yeah Watts has so much to offer us
tonight
and so we're just sort of like dancing
up to the Chevron and I walk up to the
window and I'm like I'll have a pack of
Marlboro Lights please and then I give
him a $10 bill the guy gives me back a
pack of Marlboro Lights and $15 which is
extra and look I'm a pretty honest guy
normally I would just give the money
back you gave me extra take this but I
was on acid at the time and I
don't care how honest you are your
immediate gut reaction to getting extra
money is always just hell yeah keeping
this an acid all it does is it takes
whatever emotion you're feeling and
multiplies it by 10 million so this guy
gives me extra money I look at him and
say out loud oh yeah
oh yeah I am rich man no more problems
for Dave Ross showing my girlfriend we
as we both simultaneously Monty burns
our way across the street you know
talking about all the houses and boats
and cars were gonna buy with our new
money and as we're doing that the door
of the Chevron fly's open
the dude from inside was running across
the street and starts screaming at me in
my face do my buddy you took my money
give me that money back and I don't know
what hat it's 5 bucks but I was like
it's mine you're not getting this and so
I pulled up my wallet it was in my
pocket and I showed him there's no money
in the wallet and of course the
screaming person is reasonable so what
he did was he took my wallet out of my
hand ran across the street locked
himself in the Chevron and called the
cops on me I mean you know or on himself
for stealing my wallets but either way
I'm on acid now and the cops are coming
so the next emotion I'm filled with is
just epic fear I had a bag of weed in my
pocket I gave it to my girlfriend I was
like baby take this and never come back
she just grabbed it from me he said I'll
miss you and just ran and I don't know I
don't know there was something about
seeing her run that just put me in this
like I could do this man they just
changed it was fear and now it's courage
and I turned around and in my head all
that was happening was just like Kashmir
by Led Zeppelin's playing in my head as
I'm walking up the hill to the ship it
wasn't a hill but it felt like a hill
you know
I'm walking up the hill to the Chevron
and as I'm thinking I gotta do this man
my parents can't find out I can't go to
prison I've got to make it through this
and this I'm thinking all that crazy
I I hear hey I look over and there
is a police officer in a full uniform
staring at me and I am staring at him
don't think that that happens to cops
that often I think normally with a cop
talks everyone's like sorry sir
Here I am apologies but this cop was
like hey actually he was probably just
going hey but I was hearing yeah
ah yeah so I just don't even move as he
stares at me
he stares at me hey and I'm just like
do you want just looking at him we
stare at each other for minutes probably
well that's probably ten seconds but
yeah we stare at each other for like
five thousand years for sure I'm looking
at him and he breaks eventually and he
goes hey man what happened here I just
looked him dead in his eyes and said
everything and then he said alright
you're on drugs for sure and that's when
I started crying I just started crying
immediately I didn't even try to lie I
am on drugs I'm sorry sir
don't call my dad do you know my dad I'm
sorry
and after that I could only say those
two words I'm sorry and he's just like
oh my god calm down man I'm not here to
bust you I just came for the I'm gonna
talk to that guy over there so he went
and he talked to the guy in the Chevron
came back like 17,000 years later you
know hands me my wallet back and he's
like do you have the guy's money I was
like sure here you go listen like I said
I'm not here to bust you I just want you
to be safe please tell me what drugs did
you take tonight in my head I was like
can't be acid yes it's too messed up so
I just panicked and said man
[Music]
it's like not much but yeah yeah mess so
I do mess oh my god
go home would you please go home you
live over there right you go to school
here go home I was like okay I'm sorry
as I'm walking away I got like ten steps
away from this cop and he stops me and
runs after me and he's like oh wait one
more thing was that your girlfriend I
saw walking away before I was like yeah
he goes dude Walker home don't you know
how many beatings there are in this
neighborhood thank you guys so much I'm
Dave Rob
[Applause]